Facebook's business practices get more
disturbing the more you learn about them
we learn more every day now we have new
evidence the company may be spying on
users at work and in their homes in ways
they never imagined Brett Larson is a
Fox News tech reporter and anchor for
Fox News headline 24/7 and he joins us
tonight hey Brett hey Tucker yeah we are
getting some very troubling information
about just what Facebook is learning
about their users they're listening in
on your conversations how would they do
that well it's pretty simple if you've
got the Facebook app on your phone
there's a microphone right here in fact
most of our smart phones have multiple
microphones on them so that they can
hear your voice clearly in a loud room
now Facebook denies that they are doing
this saying they have never listened in
for the purpose of advertising but many
users have gone online and folks have
even queried me in person with anecdotal
evidence that usually goes a little
something like hey so I was having this
conversation with a friend of mine and
we opened up Facebook and saw an ad
about something that we were just
discussing now this news also comes as
Christopher Wylie he is the
whistleblower seen here from Cambridge
analytic oh he actually appeared before
the British House of Commons that's
similar to our House of Representatives
and he said Facebook has the ability to
listen in so they know if you're walking
around if you're in a loud bar or if
you're at home watching TV now we
already know that Facebook tracks our
every move online every site you visit
things that you like friends that you
have also that they can build this
increasingly accurate profile about you
to sell you targeted advertising now
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg has been
invited to speak to a congressional
panel about the problems uncovered with
Facebook and actually just today the
social media giant rolling out a new
security page you'll start to see this
where you can access all your settings
for security all in one place you can
even download all of your Facebook data
in one massive download all your
pictures all your posts you'll start to
see that in the next coming days and
weeks and Tucker also today Apple CEO
Tim Cook said it is time to look and see
what can be done to ensure that when we
are online our privacy is protected very
troubling information out of Facebook
it's about time Brett thank you very
much for that thanks doctor